président quel nicole bricq et inondant
le mans terre qu'elle non seulement le
présent ou les complices et les
compétentes et qu'elle travaille sur ces
dossiers
sa personnalité n'est pas en cause et
que ses compétences non plus c'est un
choix personnel
à quels faits dans un contexte politique
qui suit son département qui lui
appartient il finit pas apporté de
commentaires pareils mais alors qu'est
ce qui s'est passé exactement
le divergence je ne sais pas du tout ce
qui s'est passé je ne suis pas à la ceni
je ne suis pas en seine-et-marne nicole
bricq ne fait part de sa décision
je n'ai pas d'autre explication que le
communiqué elle a donné communiqué on
considère aujourd'hui que les conditions
ne sont pas réunies pour qu'elle soit
candidate c'est elle qui va déroger
moi je le regrette j'aime beaucoup
nicole je te connais depuis très
longtemps on a fait un grand parcours
ensemble je sais c'est pop est en jeu
c'est sa capacité de travail s'il a
démontré la semaine dernière sur une tv
donnera sur les ordonnances
je suis un peu triste mais ça ne s'est
dit on lui appartient aux genève les
mieux à même d'apprécier la situation
locale que j'ai reçu le mail